my name is Victoria Gong and I'm
actually working with both material
science and CCL machine learning group
on my project which aims to learn mrs.
routes for advanced materials so what
does that mean what is the synthesis
route in material science often the main
goal of their project is to create a
material with a property X and this
process involves going through research
papers and then you know trial and error
experiments and if it doesn't work out
going back to research papers and then
going back to experiments and it's a
pretty long process and it can go from
any time from days to weeks to months
like this is their research revolves
around this and we want to do is be able
to help that process if you want to
create a recommendation engine to tell
you given some material let us tell you
how to create this will give you the
recipe which is the synthesis route so
it's really important for this field
because right now in material science
and there's not that much machine
learning applied actually there's a lot
of like data mining where you're saying
well let's figure out how to represent a
material but there's nothing to the
actually applies it to help you learn
something about a material the way
primarily we're trying to do this is to
create a machine learning model that
will be able to train on recipes and
materials we already know of and then
when you give us a material will tell
you the recipe to create that material